octobre 2017
l'arrestation du député guy ouellette
créé une véritable onde de choc
on accuse donc on s'excuse même si
finalement il n'a pas été accusé d'avoir
coulé de l'information sensible aux
médias la réputation de guy ouellette a
été remis il veut maintenant donner sa
version des faits ce qu'ils m'ont fait
arrêter le savent que je suis pas la
bonne personne ça servait les intérêts
de ceux qui avaient chuté aux médias
parce qu'il était contre l'idée de faire
de l'upac un corps de police autonome
avec plus de pouvoir et qu'il était le
président de la commission parlementaire
chargée d'en étudier le dossier
l'ancien grand patron robert lafrenière
aurait voulu le neutraliser guy
ouellette le compare même à l'ex patron
du fbi edgar hoover qui montaient des
dossiers contre les policiers pour les
manipuler en partant du moment où y'a un
timide les parlementaires qui m'enlève
de son chemin il n'y a plus un
parlementaire qui pose deux questions 1
du parc depuis 2010
ça ne fait pas de doute le livre créé un
certain malaise
seul le député de québec solidaire
alexandre leduc a accepté de le
commenter
en effet l'eau si on commence à faire
des accusations sans fondement on entre
dans une drôle drôle d'univers et c'est
bien dommage que toujours n'ai jamais eu
l'occasion de questionner monsieur le
preneur en commission rappelons que le
gouvernement n'a pas convoqué robert
lafrenière après sa démission
fracassante le jour des élections 2018
le premier ministre françois legault pas
lu le livre mais laisse vaguement
échapper un sous-entendu note on essaie
de prendre ce temps ce du policier guy
ouellette accusent le premier ministre
de mentir en répétant qu'il était un
informateur de la cac
ce qui a entraîné son exclusion du parti
libéral je maîtrise que gilles dit je
vous le dis publiquement ce soir là vous
regardant je ne suis pas une source de
la cac
comme ancien policier il est convaincu
que les enquêteurs de la sûreté du
québec et du spvm sont mieux qualifiés
qu'elle eut pas qu on a des problèmes de
climat de travail depuis deux mille ans
après 2017 tout le monde est parti il ya
plus d expertise on se ramasse encore
avec les mêmes problèmes
en terminant guy ouellette remettent en
question la crédibilité de l'upac une
organisation qui n'a pas su démontrer
son utilité selon lui car même dans le
dossier du financement du parti libéral
elle n'a pas non plus déposé
d'accusations ici véronique prince radio
canada québec